cpec is the place where the conservative
wing of the republican party meets once
a year the big question for the upcoming
conference is whether anyone dares to
challenge the former president or does
donald trump still control the party
ahead of the conference i met joe walsh
a former congressman who used to support
donald trump okay so
so tell me why did you support donald
trump in the first place back in 2016
i didn't pay enough attention to what a
horrible human being he was
he wasn't hillary i figured he'd play a
lot of golf and maybe nothing horrible
would happen
that wasn't the case so what did change
your mind when donald trump got elected
and i started to pay attention to him i
realized every time he opens his mouth
he lies
i'm not exaggerating politicians lie
everybody lies all politicians lie every
time trump opens his mouth he lies
i i can't support that
the final straw for me was helsinki the
summer of 2018. when donald trump stood
in front of the world and embraced putin
and gave his middle finger to our
intelligence community that was the
biggest act of disloyalty i've ever seen
in an american president i went on my
radio that night and i said i'm going to
do everything i can to make sure he's
not re-elected let's talk about cpac
this is kind of the soul-searching
yearly event for the republican party
how big is donald trump's influence
it's his party
i mean all these people on cnn and and
msnbc who talk about a fight in the
republican party bull there's no fight
this is trump's party i used to go to
cpac a lot and speak at cpac a lot
it used to be where conservatives in
america gathered
but we talked about issues
now it doesn't matter where you stand on
issues you either worship trump or you
don't and if you don't there's no place
for you
in this republican party or at cpac so
you say there is no challenger it will
probably be a governor
and it will be a governor who echoes
trump
and right now that would be ron desantis
in florida
i know ron desantis
deep down he's not a trumper
but like all republicans to get elected
he sounds like a trumper
and he's done a better job at that than
anybody i've seen in the republican
party mike pence who i know and served
with nice man he has no prayer
because of what he did on january 6. so
right now i'd say probably ron desantis
okay so if donald trump is not running
for whatever reason who is most likely
to win the nomination if donald trump
runs for president again
no republican will challenge him for the
nomination it's his
if he doesn't run there'll be a food
fight but then whoever is the most like
trump will get the nomination we have
two political parties in this country we
need more than two
but two major political parties
one of our major political parties
has become a cult
and an anti-democratic cult
that should scare the world topics used
to matter in the republican party is is
there any topic the gop cares about the
republican party is a cult
so they do not stand for issues they
stand for
devotion to one man
back in 2020 every election
every four years every presidential
election the democratic party and the
republican party put forth a platform
that tells the world where they stand on
issues
for the first time ever in 2020 the
republican party did not put forth a
platform
they didn't tell the world where they
stood on taxes or guns or health care
all they said was we stand for the
re-election of donald trump
so
it really the party doesn't stand much
more for just advancing trump and
trumpism tell me what is trumpism
it's build a wall around the country
keep people who are not white people out
deny the truth
and support
authoritarianism to get what you want
what makes me unusual is i voted for
trump in 2016. i come from that world
i used to think republicans believed in
freedom and limited government they
don't
i want a dictator who will build a wall
around the country and keep brown people
out it's an authoritarian party now
that's scary